there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could hey everybody it's
Charlie I got a bunch of requests to do
a Black Widow video because they
confirmed that they're gonna be doing
the movie they hired a director so it's
real now the movie isn't vaporware
anymore so what kind of backdoor
confirms that she's going to survive the
end of Avengers 4 and will resign
whatever new contract she needs to do
this movie in any future appearances so
we got to break all this down if you're
brand new to the channel there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this first things first the name
of the director that they hired is Kate
Shortland she's an Australian director
that's directed a lot of neo-noir
spy thriller Berlin Syndrome lore it's
ok if you haven't watched the stuff that
she's done before it's just that her
pedigree flows from the genres that you
would expect a black widow movie to be
noir spy thriller action movie probably
a good example is is them doing a movie
like atomic blonde which is a comic book
movie but that's kind of the cringy
version of a black widow movie with a
ton of pop music remember all the memes
when Jennifer Lawrence did that red
Sparrow movie that was a bad version of
a Black Widow movie do not watch that
you're totally fine skipping that just
the ideas that it's not hard to do a
black widow movie so we'll talk about
her after Avengers 4 and phase 4 like
what her characters gonna look like in
the future but the big stuff first
obviously part of it is going to take
place in present day so they'll have to
deal with the consequences of what
happens during infinity war and Avengers
4 remember she's been one of Captain
America's Secret Avengers since Civil
War so she's actually been very active
in the world trying to dismantle the
arms trade with Captain America all off
spider-man homecoming like there was a
prelude comic book that showed you what
they've been doing so in the way that
the Marvel movies sort of build on each
other the consequences of what she's
been doing should inform some of the
adventure that she's on in present day
like you imagined that the movie opens
with a big action scene she's in the
middle of dismantling some giant arms
deal like think somebody that would run
with ulysses klaw like that
- Captain America's Secret Avengers has
been going after for the last couple of
years since civil war so that comes back
to bite them in the ass they're taking
one of them down but one of the tropes
of Marvel movies that deal with origins
I don't know if you would call it a
trope is is that you have a problem in
present day but you also have a problem
from the past come back to haunt the
hero that's somehow connected to what's
happening in present day they just did
it with the ghost character during
ant-man of the wasp so you have like
this problem in present day the quantum
realm but then you have Hank PIMs past
misdeeds coming back to bite them in the
ass literally that becomes connected
with the quantum realm plot so what is
the version of that for the Black Widow
it's all the red on her ledger it's the
Red Room we've gotten a few flashbacks
to that there was the age of Ultron
flashbacks I think there was a moment
during civil war where she said she
tried to find her parents graves because
she didn't really know her parents
because she was sent to the Red Room at
a very young age so that's about all we
know of the past of MCU Black Widow so
somebody from the Red Room should come
back to bite her on the ass or some read
from her ledger comes back to bite her
in the ass maybe a better example would
be Hydra and Bucky coming back to bite
Captain America in the ass during the
Winter Soldier movie something from his
past that's connected to present-day
problems so you have Hydra and
present-day but you also a Bucky and
Hydra from the past coming back what is
the black widow version of that
conveniently she has her own version of
the Winter Soldier name Jelena Bulova
the second person to take the mantle
there was a comic book storyline where
she actually tried to hunt down - Tasha
Romanoff kill her and literally take the
mantle from her like I'm going to become
the next Black Widow by killing the
original they can incorporate that
character with a version of her
backstory they simplify everything from
the movies quite a bit so you could just
have Black Widow killing people while
she's in the Red Room working for the
Soviets they could be connected to
Jelena Bulova or somebody in present-day
that comes back to bite her in the ass
just remember she has a lot of red on
her ledger
that's a bit of a JJ Abrams mystery box
anything can come out of that any
character from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that's the beauty of having a
character say like Black Panther the
travels all over the world is they can
interact with anybody in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that you want any
big villain that you want to include or
they haven't done yet anybody from the
Masters of evil any of the bigger
sinister six characters like Norman
Osborn like Black Widow can go anywhere
you want her to go but what about other
Avengers characters crossing over I
think we are all in agreement in saying
that the top of that list should be
Winter Soldier in Hawkeye and depending
on what happens to him at the end of
Avengers 4 Captain America so you just
continue some of the threads of what the
Secret Avengers have been doing on the
DL this whole time into present day in
the Black Widow movie but then some
shared past comes back to haunt them so
who has shared history amongst that
group with Black Widow cap was on ice
that whole time so he's really only
known Black Widow over the last 10 years
or so but the really cool thing about
the Winter Soldier character is that he
was also an assassin for the Soviets
that they would just de thaw every time
they needed him to take down someone
really big so he would come in and out
of cryogenic stasis throughout the years
meaning that he could have been around
when Black Widow was training in the Red
Room in her early years working for the
Soviet government so it's pretty easy to
guess that they probably share some read
on their respective Ledger's like there
was probably a time where they ran into
each other while they were on different
hits I know who killed fury most of the
intelligence community doesn't believe
he exists the ones that do call him the
Winter Soldier he's credited with over
two dozen assassinations in the last 50
years so he's a ghost story
five years ago I was escorting a nuclear
engineer out of Iran somebody shot out
my tires near Odessa we lost control
went straight over a cliff I pulled us
out but the Winter Soldier was there I
was covering my engineer so he shot him
straight through me
Soviet slug no rifling bye-bye bikinis
yeah but you look terrible in a mountain
they teamed up quite a bit so they do
have a lot of comic book history it's
just that the Marvel movies haven't done
a whole lot with that because we haven't
had a black widow or a Winter Soldier
movie yet in the last Winter Soldier
movie was really a Captain America movie
so they didn't really involve Black
Widow a lot in that but she did talk
about The Legend of Winter Soldier so it
implies that she knew who he was in
Hawkeye I think that should just include
because he needs more screen time and
there's the rumor of the Cape Bishop
Hawkeye movie that they're developing
Marvel hasn't confirmed that yet but the
idea is that eventually Jeremy Renner
would not do Marvel movies anymore and
they would do a version of the fraction
Hawkeye run where he passes the mantle
to Kate Bishop as for her Captain
America that would really just be a
continuation of Secret Avengers this is
still black widows movie so it would
mostly focus on her and when you
flashback to the Red Room or if you have
Winter Soldier in those flashbacks you
still be seeing that from her
perspective but just remember she's sort
of a blank canvas when it comes to those
flashbacks she could have run up against
any big classic Marvel villain that you
could think of like they bring back so
many deep cuts during ant-man of the
wasp from the classic Avengers because
of Janet Van Dyne s character because
she was a founding member but just to
chart the timeline just to put things
into perspective when you see all the
flashbacks to Michael Douglas in ant-man
that's to like the really late 80s early
90s you have to imagine that Black Widow
didn't actually start going on missions
to like the mid to late 90s when she was
a little bit older remember she's still
supposed to be relatively young in the
MCU so I don't think that she came up to
like the tail end of the Soviet Union
and then just probably started working
for the KGB because if you really want
to be a stickler about it the Soviet
Union was gone by the time she would
have been old enough to actually be
going on assassination missions so
they'll probably explain some of that
backstory when they get to the movie I
wouldn't worry about that too much right
now but let me know in the comments who
do you want the villain of the Black
Widow movie to be and which other
Avengers do you want to cross over into
that don't forget that Comic Con is next
week so I'll do a video in the next
couple of days explaining what the
trailer schedule is going to be in the
videos that I'm going to be doing but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner plain rock one to four please
email me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for all my ant-man of the wasp
dregg's and click here for that post
credit scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]